with thanks to curiosity stream and
nebula for sponsoring this video
oh now you give me these yes now i do
okay now i can do science and i can look
rad as hell while doing it
i can see why this field appeals to some
people lots of people follow this
youtube channel because of the vlogs i
made during my phd in atmospheric
physics at the university of exeter
unfortunately however i had to graduate
at some point and that necessarily meant
the end of my videos showing what doing
a phd was like however there are lots of
people out there doing interesting phd
projects and so in this video series i'm
spending a few days with a new
researcher each episode showing you what
that life is like learning a bit about
them and learning about the topic of
their thesis this episode i've taken the
eurostar to the netherlands to speak to
a phd student at the university of
wageningen whose research is on
something you studied in school my name
is francesco i'm italian i'm a fourth
year phd candidate here at wageningen
university at the laboratory of genetics
where i work on photosynthesis
photosynthesis is the
last non-explored yield determining
trait that we can still exploit to
improve the yield of our crops we know a
lot about this beautiful process of
converting the radiating energy from the
sun into the chemical energy that then
sets into the sugars that power our
planet our ecosystems in the end but we
do not know a lot about um how
photosynthesis changes how
photosynthesis has been adapted to
challenging environments and we also we
do not know a lot about how we can make
photosynthesis more efficient in order
to do that in my project we will look at
natural variation so called for
photosynthesis specifically we look into
the family of brassy casey which is a
widespread well-known also rather
important
planned family so in my project we're
just trying to break down the um
the blueprint
for getting
high photosynthesis in such a species
that still shares most of the classical
photosynthesis mechanisms with many
other low-performing species and for
context when francesco talks about a
species having higher photosynthesis
he's talking about a species
photosynthesizing between 50 and 100
more efficiently than key crops like
wheat and rice
this isn't some small improvement this
is potentially
huge the question is how does that
species do it we all know there's this
formula that we studied in order to make
photosynthesis happen you need carbon
dioxide light and you need water and
what you get out is well oxygen and
sugars photosynthesis it's not it's not
a stable process as environment changes
it's an extremely dynamic process and
that makes perfect sense when you think
how plants grow in nature they grow
under an environment which you know
clouds come by the sun irradiance
changes you could have rain or you could
have fog and all of these environmental
factors mean that photosynthesis is
extremely dynamic and only now we're
starting to get a bit of an idea about
how dynamic it is and and what makes it
such such a complicated process part of
our work or actually ultimately all of
our work is supposed to end up in stuff
like this stuff we eat stuff that
produces the food that ultimately ends
up on our tables but also that feeds
the animals we rely on and so on and so
forth you may not have thought about the
science that goes on in putting food on
your table but when it comes to growing
food every last percentage fraction of a
percent makes a difference when it comes
to agricultural yields and that means
some serious science and some serious
hardware we're currently standing in
one of the greenhouses we have available
for research here at wageningen
university this is kind of the center of
our operations in a way this is where a
lot of our research happens because we
have access to this uh to these various
sizes of greenhouse compartments this is
where we do most of the growing of our
plants we have two compartments which
are the most classical greenhouse
compartments you can think about and
there but they are equipped with with
this gantry system which will basically
go over plants over time and is equipped
with a lot of cameras it can do like
thermal imaging it can do near infrared
imaging you can do rgb imaging and this
already gives us a wealth of data we
we've never had access to to be honest
we have
two other compartments which i think are
the coolest ones they feature a fully
automated conveyor belt system a
computer will be taking care of moving
plants around so you can use that to
kind of shuffle the plants around and
move them if you want to for example
counter some some environmental effects
but also what's even more important than
this is that you see the greenhouse has
doors the conveyor belt system will then
take the plants that are growing into
this greenhouse out of these doors and
onto a whole set of measurement
equipment that we have in the next
corridor this can grow up to 500 plants
and in a matter of hours give us
complete data set for example on the
photosynthetic performance all of all of
them this is something that we could
only dream of a few years ago but this
facility is a bit too general for my
work working with light i need to work
with something a bit more specialized i
need to be able to literally play with
light to satellite levels and to grow my
plants at different light levels at the
beginning of my phd
this was not easy simply by
technological limitations leds were not
that powerful i ended up building this
building this light sealing setup in my
into into this into this growth chamber
and this allows me to grow plants
simultaneously
under two different light conditions at
the moment we're standing uh under the
low light level so this is 200
micro moles of photons per square meter
per second and in in in general terms
that's that's a cloudy day while to the
back of the chamber for obvious reasons
we usually apply the highlight
treatments and we're able to go up to
1800 micro moles of flight per square
square meter per second that is like the
the point irradiance you could measure
at midday around the summer solstice in
a very bright day around these latitudes
around the netherlands um but we apply
that for 12 hours a day so that's a lot
it's it's what we call a supernatural
irradiance the typical day in in a
climate room or maybe half day in a
climate room involves things like well
for example setting the light levels we
have all of this connected to each and
every driver of each and every light
that feeds back into a raspberry pi
computer it basically gives us unlimited
possibilities for playing with light so
now you see this is steady radiance it's
always the same but we can do all sorts
of variations fluctuations you name it
plant germination for starters this is
like how lately we work with our plants
so we do germinate our seeds directly
onto this this kind of rockwool plugs
this is a general plant care or or
glorified gardening view if you wish
because of course everything here is
done uh with with prime materials and we
work with like uh production
horticulture grade stuff like rockwool
and so on this is lower light levels on
this side
ah
this is as what did you say it was as
bright as the solstice mid-day this is
in the netherlands
in the netherlands for 12 hours a day
i may have damaged my cameras
like burned them in my like i would not
i can literally barely see the camera it
is that bright it is extraordinarily
bright in here this is one of those
hazards of the job they do not warn you
about i stayed in wageningen for a
couple of days and historical side note
i actually stayed in the hotel where
german forces occupying the netherlands
capitulated to the allies at the end of
world war ii in fact the breakfast room
downstairs is where that capitulation
actually happened
almost certainly the most like
monumental place i've ever had a
croissant and to get around town well if
you're in the netherlands you're gonna
cycle
so not only is just cycling very dutch
i'm specifically having to get used to
this dutch style of bike which you may
notice has no
brakes there's nothing on the handlebars
apart from you know the bar so in order
to to break i'm having to reverse pedal
and
it takes some getting used to i've
nearly crashed a couple of times
the cycling infrastructure here is
incredible there are like super highways
here for
thousands of bikes like
why can't we have more of this this is
awesome i don't mean the brakes
i mean this infrastructure
i think i'm getting the hang of it now
this is the bit i normally forget to
vlog properly so i'm going to try and do
it this time the other reason that i'm
in town as well as talking to francesco
is i'm giving some talks i'm actually
giving a talk today in this space which
is just
it's really look there's like an
l-shaped seating pattern
and then there's the screen the lectern
and a grand piano so i could just sort
of give an impromptu recital if
if the mood takes me
i should probably learn these slides i
am very happy and excited to
see
simon clark here thank you very much for
coming everyone in person and online i
hope this is going to be interesting
[Music]
i finally got footage of me giving a
talk on one of these trips thanks
francesco i think that went well um it
was a bit of a frankenstein talk this
one because it was trying to do lots of
things it's like a cycom audience but
it's also
researchers and they also wanted to know
about like my story and
yeah there's a lot lots of things
happening on that talk but i think it
went all right even if i think it didn't
go very well i'm actually giving another
talk tomorrow so i get another bite at
the cherry
[Music]
so out there there's a row of white
coats right we had to put these on
because of the grade of lab that it's in
and then francesca says right we're
gonna go film in here we literally
walked
less than 10 meters what got me here
actually started even before i went to
university so i was lucky in in high
school in italy to have a brilliant
sciences teacher
she she basically devolved the whole of
our 50 which is the final year of our
biology classes to biotechnology i got
really interested in that and then i i i
just kind of decided that i i want to
study biotechnology because hey that's
cool you know genes dna molecular
biology it's really crazy stuff i went
to the university of turin torino um and
i did a bachelor's in in biotechnology
which was uh mostly focusing on on
medical applications because that's
pretty strong there we had a few like
optional courses we could pick and i
ended up doing all of that into into
plant discipline so i did a bit of plant
genetics plant plant breeding and plant
physiology and i just i just got really
interested in that i've always kind of
enjoyed like agriculture and thinking
about it and then like kind of seeing
the connection between the two so like
hey i can still do biotechnology but it
actually really links to stuff out in
the fields
that i think is really what what
what what what clicked with me and i was
like okay so i want to move on
and and work further with plants but
then a friend of mine one day like
completely randomly and he was like yeah
you know there's this place in the
netherlands
wagon whatever um and yeah they're like
a leading university and this and that
so yeah i'm considering applying there
for for my masters and i was like okay i
went over i went to the website i took a
look at it and in five minutes i i made
my mind i was like okay i want to be
there i want to study there i i i want
to do it it looked so cool so i came
here in wageningen for my master's where
i studied plant biotechnology and i
think you can do in the netherlands as a
almost
finished student is you can write a phd
proposal you can submit it to the
national funding agency and there's
every year there's a few calls you can
participate too it's very hard it's the
level is extremely high and usually you
have like
per call you have 20 to 30 applicants
and only four usually gets get the money
so we did that we wrote a proposal we
wrote this
beautiful over-ambitious crazy proposal
that was oh man that
that was that was fun that was really
fun to make so of course i didn't get it
in the meantime private funders
were interested in
investing some money and we had this
kind of big over-ambitious proposal uh
sitting around
and so it was decided that they would
invest in it it would be kind of like be
divided between researchers and then i
got the job
and here i am four years later can i get
you just a point and do compare between
the two
yes i i just need the closest yeah this
is bad
i do love working with students as a
general statement i really do enjoy
sharing what i do and
sharing what i know and also also
sharing all of my struggles with them
because they need to learn and they need
to see everything as as it's happening
so i really do enjoy spending time with
them i do enjoy chatting with them or or
getting stuck with them or getting lost
with them or or having also all sorts of
trouble with them can you describe what
it feels like to be a scientific pioneer
like you are doing stuff right it's a
totally different thing and you're
training up the next generation of
people what does that feel like so the
first thing about being a scientific
pioneer is feeling extremely weird when
being called that it is of course
exciting it's exciting when you look
back and when you think hey i'm i'm one
of the first people to be doing this uh
it's of course also extremely
challenging because there's nobody else
you can turn to with your problems and
and with your struggles it feels again
like a privilege to be able to to
immediately kind of train a next
generation of scientists uh into into my
little tiny tiny niche because it really
gives them a
a very good idea of what science can be
of how exciting it can be of how hard it
can be of how frustrating it can be um
so i think that's why i like having
students around and that's why i like
really showing them around because i
think being with me they get all the
good and all the bad and so they get a
they get a very good idea for themselves
of whether they like doing science or
not
being on campus something that becomes
apparent very quickly is just how much
money has been invested in this place
and specifically just how much money has
been invested by corporations so we just
had lunch in here which is the unilever
place on site it's not like a
headquarters or anything
it's it's their food innovation center
so some kind of r d
center headquarters
and but and it's an example you've
pointed out to lots of buildings of of
uh corporations
one two three the the biggest one on
campus we have a couple of buildings
filled with like smaller companies
startups and so on
and these are all companies that have
basically put stuff on campus and they
interact with the research that takes
place here yeah yeah that's the idea
that's why they ideally they come on
campus to to just share facilities and
they have easy access to the people in
the university maybe the
staff or the students it's very common
for uh this is mostly food companies so
many many food sciences students they
just you know it's an easy internship
and job here so it's a completely
different model of like financing
university at least in europe this is
very
american way of doing things and it's
like
it's it's just different it's very very
different to what i'm i've experienced
before at least in europe so vacanting
is a
small town it's like probably got 30 000
inhabitants and on top of that you have
to stack 10 000 students we usually
refer to it as a bit of a bubble we're
we're not in a very international area
of of the netherlands if you wish but
here like you literally walk around town
and hear all sorts of languages it's a
small township you kind of end up
knowing any everyone after after a while
it's got a very cozy feeling to it it's
a rather unique experience i would say
it's a good place to get stressed
if you wish but besides that this is a
good place because well a we're in the
netherlands and this is i think maybe
the last country in europe that employs
us it is very nice to be considered
staff of the university not just as
students and of course there is a
hierarchy in the chair groups in the
university but
it is not a very strong hierarchy from
the moment you you enter a chair group
you feel people are interested in you
and and hearing what you think and in
you doing your job for yourself not for
somebody else so i really appreciate
that i really do appreciate this mindset
where were you really valued for for
what you are and you're
not just seen as a pair of hands getting
set up for talk number two and as always
when you're going to university there is
always a different it set up and you
always have to work it out five minutes
before you're giving a presentation how
many phds does it take
oh that went well how can we feed a
planet that's going to have
10 billion people on it like what how
much of a challenge is that
that is a big challenge
we're not gonna lie here it's it's a
massive challenge especially when you
think that we do not only have a
population problem we also have a
climate problem right so we're not only
looking um in the agricultural sector as
we need to produce more food
we need to produce more food with less
land available under
more threats and with less fertilizers
pesticides and you name it it's a long
shot of course we're not directly going
to just deliver
a solution to the problem but we hope
that giving like you know a little
puzzle piece that we can put together
with many other puzzle pieces and and
use to eventually get to the solution of
the problem but by understanding how my
species and many other species do do
better at photosynthesis we can really
compile a list of targets basically and
then go into into our crops into into
our fields and screen for these targets
we are getting much better at selection
we're getting much better measurements
we're getting much better at crossing so
we can skip a lot of a lot of steps uh
thanks to modern technologies but yes
it's still not going to be next year
it's it's a it's a it's a long-term
process we are trying to produce like an
atlas describing possibilities to
achieve higher photosynthesis rates for
specific purposes in a number of plants
when we have that sorted out then we can
kind of deliver it to the breeders the
people that really make our crops that
really are at the basis of our food
production systems and tell them hey
these are all the solutions there are
available
take your crops
and figure out what the most convenient
solution is for your specific
application so
we will not be able to feed the world
with one
gene with one plant with one application
with one idea but we need a whole set
of possibilities available to improve
the yield of our crops and then lastly
very briefly the question that everybody
hates as a student what's next after the
phds i have no clue so i have roughly a
year left so it's really it's really the
time i need to push through get the
final bits of work done and then write
up i do not think i will stay in
academia i i've seen it enough now and i
do not think that's a good fit for me i
can appreciate a company job i i can see
how it works and what are the ups and
downs
but i'm also considering all sorts of
like alternative careers like i know
like in front of me i have standing the
the
the textbook example of an alternative
career after after getting after getting
a phd and and that's very attractive to
me so i'm really considering all sorts
of like alternative careers but i i
really can't put a finger on it it's
really like
i have no clue nobody knows that's the
big secret nobody knows nobody knows
i hope this video has made you think
about the science that goes into putting
food on your plate but it doesn't just
stop with science the food we grow and
how we grow it has changed a lot over
the past 10 000 years and if that sounds
interesting you should watch the history
of food one of thousands of
documentaries available on
curiositystream who have kindly
sponsored this video curiositystream is
the number one source of high quality
documentaries on the internet with
titles for kids and adults both short
and long form and spanning subjects from
travel to genetics you can get access to
curiosity stream by heading to
curiositystream.com simon clark and get
two extras firstly 26 off meaning it
costs just over a dollar a month and
free access to nebula nebula is of
course the streaming service owned and
operated by a collection of educational
youtubers including me on nebula we post
our videos early along with exclusive
content available nowhere else such as
real life laws series on modern
conflicts or the collaborative series
working titles by watching on nebula you
directly support educational creators
and diversify the ecosystem of online
video meaning we're not all entirely
reliant on youtube but more than that
you will see no adverts anywhere it's a
much more pleasant less algorithmic
viewing experience for you so head to
curiositystream.com simon clark to get
access to the best documentaries on the
internet and support groundbreaking
educational content for just over a
dollar a month with thanks to
curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
new sets not finished
sorry thank you so much for watching
this video i really hope you enjoyed
this one because i love making these phd
stories episodes there are more coming
in the future so if you enjoyed this one
and you're not already please do
subscribe to the channel to watch more
huge thanks must also go to francesco
please do check the description for
links to his social media give him a
follow learn more about plant science if
you'd like to recommend viewing next
here's some videos from me and if you
enjoyed the video please do pop it a
like and if you're not already as
already said please do consider
subscribing that just leads me to say
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one